it's no such thing as overnight nothing
there's no overnight stick it ain't no
overnight success no overnight
Sensations
[Applause]
that thing that you're looking at that
looks like an overnight success is not
real it's gonna go away real [ __ ]
fast because it ain't got no Foundation
Instead This is why I say that
if you go directly from zero to 100 with
anything in life what you're doing to
yourself you don't realize what you're
doing but you're doing it what you're
doing to yourself is you're robbing
yourself of the journey that's where all
the magic is at the experience of the
[ __ ] Journey that's why all the
beautiful [ __ ] takes place it's only
it's on the way there
today when you get there it's getting
there that's the beautiful part
so if you go directly from zero to 100
Toronto that means you missing out on
27. you just skipping 27. the 27 feel
pretty good when you finally get to 27.
there you go for 27 you get to 32 then
you go to 45. then you get to 70
something you like damn [ __ ] I remember
when I was at zero my life is just mad
routine at this point and I like it so
to go shoot a video to shoot a doc to
even just come downstairs
and do this yeah I swear to God bro I
swear yo that's the level of like
Comfort slash laziness that I've like
I've reached in my life I had to make a
real decision
are you okay we're getting comfortable
chilling mailing it in waiting around on
inspiration
if this is as high as you ever got not
Career Success wise but from a
skill level like have you wrote your
best song did you leave no stone
unturned creatively and when I thought
about that feeling I was like nah I'm
not cool like when you start meditating
that's supposed to happen all it's
showing you is that and all it's showing
me and showing all of us is that like
I'm not in control I'm letting my mind
like run the show which is fine
[Music]
I don't want that to happen for myself
you know I mean I don't want to be like
a slave
to my thoughts yes you know what I mean
like I don't want to and and I feel like
that's how I've been living my life yeah
being like a slave to like my thoughts
and 98 of my thoughts ain't even my
thoughts it's something I seen on
Twitter heard on TV something my mom
told me when I was younger something
somebody else said so these thoughts are
like
fears and worries or like just ideas
from other people and it's like that
stuff is controlling me uncomfortable
moments you find out a lot about
yourself
and usually you find out that you're
capable of rising to that bar that's set
by that uncomfortable situation
so what's something I could do yo when
somebody bring you a feature say yes
I was looking at it like an opportunity
for growth do you really want to look
back and be like you didn't work with
nobody you didn't have no songs and
nobody that you just cool with that no
okay so start saying yes some features
similarly it was like that with letting
people know yo the off-season it's a boy
fall off is coming it's like yo
now that the possibility of not doing
this [ __ ] seems real and I'm at peace
with that
don't have a regret there's a mentality
that I had that was never shaken and it
was quiet it wasn't outspoken it was a
quiet it was all in here so the minute
where that changes you know what I mean
and now I'm dealing with a mindset that
I never had to deal with before was like
fighting all these negative thoughts
that's the dark place I'm talking about
like
self-confidence kind of shattered you
know what I mean and like trying to
fight against that I'm writing my way
out of it you know what I mean and just
just this whole album was writing my way
out of that place because I had never
had to deal with that before like I was
a you know I mean I was a happy kid I
wasn't like a down kid like I observed
life and I saw like it was positives and
negatives but I wasn't like a depressed
child you know I mean so when I had to
deal with that type of my estate
I wasn't speaking on it so then when I
tell people like yo you know I was up
for this whole album like you know I was
like
like doubting myself this whole time
[ __ ] like what
you serious but it was real to me I was
like be like yo pressure is real man
that's why people jump off of buildings
man like
it just ended
it doesn't matter what's what the story
was behind the pressure pressure is
pressure
LeBron James had pressure he makes
millions of dollars but when he wasn't
one of them sips
please believe he was stressed had to be
because that pressure is is real and
sometimes the pressure is so strong you
can't even see what you got in front of
you which is like
you can see you can't see that like you
got a real life in front of you got
friends that love you family love you
kids and love you but you're just so
worried about this that it dominates all
your thoughts and it now interferes with
your life and that's when people end it
we got college students that ended
just because it was depression the
competitive nature of school was too
much for them to take and we know like
yo it's just college man you know what I
mean you'll be all right but press it
feels the same no matter what situation
you're in it's too because I basically
State my intentions like ass
for like guidance like y'all know these
words these people pay hard-earned money
yeah to come to this show let me nail
everything let me try things I haven't
done before that's a prayer like I'm
asking for like guidance and like help
in that area the meditation for me is
more like
being present I'm not
trying to think anything I'm not praying
about anything I'm just still observing
so if my mind is racing and it might be
nerves or it might be there's a bill due
or it might be
this is happening in a family I'm
noticing it and I'm trying to let it go
slow Let It Go but also not fight it
bring my attention back to like my
breathing something that's currently
happening
the sound of that fan huh I just listen
and try to like focus on that and what
you'll notice is like
your my mind will start going to
something else like oh my mom said
something on the phone boom and I'll
start thinking about that and I might go
on a 30-second trip on that thought and
then I catch it like oh
look what just happened it's fine let me
bring my attention back
to that fan something that's like
present moment and like that I want to
become a person that does that every day
not just when like I feel anxiety or I
feel stressed because I I'm like yo I
see what it does for me
in those moments when like things are
like stressful or like I'm feeling
anxious it settles me it brings me like
back to the current moment I can't
imagine what it would do for me if you
did it every day on a Tuesday in the
crib you know I mean like somebody in
this building
show up in your life that's all you ever
think about is what you want to do
can't wait to manifest that's your
favorite word girl can't wait to
manifest
manifestation
and some days you get a little down a
little depressing because
it just ain't happening fast enough for
you when they're like damn is this [ __ ]
ever gonna come you get frustrated I'm
gonna tell you like this Toronto if this
message applies to you
do not [ __ ] quit whatever you do
don't stop don't do that don't get it
you'll regret that [ __ ] forever
do not stop
this [ __ ] don't happen overnight this is
a step-by-step process so you got to put
one foot in front of the other that's
how this should work that's how it goes
I don't give a [ __ ]
even if somebody in this building right
now had the magical ability
to just snap their fingers and take you
from zero to a hundred so when they snap
their fingers when you wake up tomorrow
in the morning everything you ever
wanted in this world is gonna be right
there when you wake up even if somebody
could do that I promise you
Toronto you do not want it like that
you don't want it like that
[Applause]